your kids they deserve do you know what
happens when your Google your name sweet
cheese first thing that pops up to know
it's the breast enhancement no no 20
it's this all these articles about that
you have not aged breast enhancement
president oh really did you have an age
because I usually be in a bird box why
am I'm sleeping your nuts container that
is devoid of outside carcinogens that
helps lift mm-hmm
what you don't have and it makes it and
it just come on please I look at you the
only time you see me is when I do press
junkets do you know how many hours of
hair and makeup this took two and a half
hour two and a half hours this gets
washed up I'm gonna work this look all
day today and I'm gonna go home and take
a shower and then it's gonna happen
again at 8 o'clock in the morning that
you I'm never out in the world where I
get photographed unless it's and things
like that so I just looked my best
the truth is stopped before said
everyday so you saw up in her work out
she works out every aspect
what's because there's a whole
competition you needed to look even
wasn't hard competition but yeah I know
yeah but he'd get something like four
and works out for two hours of the
journey carries around a little juggle
water constantly hydrating this guy
that's like in-between shots you know I
would be like we none of us ever
leftover supposed to be there might be
some house that train would be up on
some rock or some tree just reading like
the key would be like we go cheering
philosophy and you just stop and you
went that's real that's real that wasn't
for show because he's tucked away
somewhere but like he's he's constantly
looking inward
listen to me
you're going on the trip now it's going
to be rough
if you hear something in the woods you
tell me you know what else is real if
there was a moment with the children
where you could tell as any parent could
see it's like that moment where you
really you tell your kids something and
they start listening yeah did you take
that from real life with your kid
because I've had that moment where I'm
gonna I don't want to hear yeah well you
you know that you can go there I try
really hard not to go there with my kids
but you do that when you're scared you
know when your child about runs into
traffic
it is the fear and the Beast that comes
out you had to stay in beast mode of the
fear of what would happen if something
like this happened to my kids and you
become a human being you don't like but
it's the only thing you know how to do
no circumstance you guys have on
blindfold you're running through the
world you're right how much stuff did
you hit is this the person who ran into
everything the person no I've no let's
let's this clarify I ran into the matte
box twice because we had an amazing
Steadicam operator who knew how to move
the camera away but I would switch
directions and I wouldn't Matt box is a
little piece of metal that's off the the
lens that sort these little flaps hit
them twice which were my fault
the third time was not my fault when I
put there I had to climb up the hill
there's a scene when I'm climbing up a
ravine and they'd set the three cameras
and I practice blindfold I got the
feeling for it and then after I
practiced the DP moved the camera again
and I got up and I took off running and
my face hit the mat box and there was
blood in that yeah that's when he had
the little baby meltdown because I was
frightened when I saw it wasn't six
inches wide it was just an inch but at
first you were tripping oh I was I had
I've had a moment it was tired I missed
my kids I hadn't seen them in three
weeks I was having I mean I saw them on
the weekends but I had
little tiny meltdown
[Music]